der durchschnittsdeutsche gibt pro monat
rund 242 euro für lebensmittel und
restaurants aus das sind auch den tag
gerechnet rund acht euro ziehen um älter
sein gebe ich über das doppelte davon
aus auch weil ich oft essen gehe und oft
bestelle für den nächsten sieben tage
aber werde ich nicht nur für acht euro
pro tag essen sowie unsere
durchschnittsdeutsche sondern für ein
europa sie keinen einzigen cent mehr
ich werde zuerst genau ausrechnen wie
viel essen ich mir von meinen sieben
euro doch ein budget leisten kann und
dann einkaufen gehen anschließend teste
ich ob man davon überhaupt satz wird und
wie es mir dabei geht über 15 mal
günstiger zu speisen als sonst und zu
guter letzt werde ich nach diesem
experiment in richtig gutes restaurant
gehen um zu testen ließ sich danach
anfühlt wieder etwas für über einen euro
zu essen
dieses video wird unterstützt von mir
selbst in der video beschreibung findet
ihr den trailer zu meinem schnittkurs
mit dem man schnell alles lernen lassen
verschnitt von musikvideos urlaubsvideos
oder youtube-videos braun
ich bin gerade auf einer website auf der
man die preise der gängigen supermärkte
in deutschland überprüfen kann
ich hab mir natürlich den günstigsten
supermarkt aus dagegen ausgewählt und
ich könnte mir vorstellen das reißt ihn
nicht kennst du das was man kriegt ein
kilogramm reis kostet hier nur 1 euro
und ich denke für ein kilogramm reis da
kann man nicht glaube ich ein paar tage
verreisen deswegen kommt er auf jeden
fall schon mal auf die einkaufsliste
damit ich in dieser woche nicht nur
kohlenhydrate essen könnte ich meine
forschungen als linsen ganz praktisch
sind weil die haben nämlich auch noch
recht albers sind aber auch ansonsten
ziemlich günstig und kosten hier ein
euro pro 500 gramm als doppelt so teuer
vor gewicht wie der reis aber aber die
linsen kommen auf jeden fall auch noch
auf dem einkaufszettel
was wirklich ganz wie es ist
amerikas pro kilo nur 39 cent und davon
kann man ja mal mega viel brot backen
und hilfe kostet auch nur zwölf cent und
sonstigen war dafür eigentlich noch salz
das kostet 19 cent
das auch mal war ich habe mich jetzt
noch für milchreis entschieden weil ich
gerne das hätte dafür brauchen wir
zucker und natürlich milch dann zu dem
wohl wasserbecken brocken natürlich
irgendwie noch butter auf jeden fall und
vielleicht auch was müsste es deswegen
nämlich noch nicht nur creme und dann
haben wir auch eigentlich schon alles
dann haben wir die sieben euro ziemlich
gut ausgereizt ich glaube mehr kriegen
oder nicht aus ich hoffe einfach dass
ich diese woche nicht zu verhungern muss
und ich hoffe auch dass es einigermaßen
erträglich ist zu eintönig ohne gewürze
und alles zu essen wir gehen jetzt mal
einkaufen
es ist schon ein komisches gefühl beim
einkaufen derartig limitiert zu sein und
so extrem auf den preis abzusehen da ist
vor ort leider doch keine linsen gab
habe ich mich dazu entschieden diese
spontan durch spaghetti und tomatensoße
zu ersetzen der puderzucker hat leider 4
cent mehr gekostet wie auf der webseite
ausgeschrieben und der milchreis sogar
zehn die hefe hat dafür aber nur 9 cent
gekostet anstatt der günstige den 15
prozentigen milch werde ich die teurere
3,5 prozentige nehmen da ich die dann
noch mit wasser verdünnen kann und
dadurch noch mehr hat außerdem nehme ich
noch eine packung bio karotten mit 4 77
cent für diesen luxus muss ich dann
jedoch die deutlich teurere butter durch
die günstigere margarine ersetzen wollen
der ich zugegebenermaßen nicht so ein
großer fan bin bevor ich dann zur kasse
gegangen bin habe ich noch mal exakt
nachgerechnet dann würde ich auch ja
nichts zurücklegen muss der moment der
wahrheit kommt und siehe da 6 eur 92
punktlandung ganz raus geschafft haben
es auf 6 eur 92 geschafft also knapp
unter den sieben cent bleibt nicht mal
mehr für die 19 hilfe noch mal
zusätzlich gereicht ich habe mir
überlegt für die 10 cent auch irgendwie
was vom chaos zu holen ich glaube 18
jetzt kriegst du gar nichts mehr denken
wir können uns die mich glücklich
schätzen und ich freue mich schon vor
allem auf die karotten weil ich glaube
die ganze zeit nur so kohlenhydrate zeug
zu essen ist auch richtig eklig
ich finde es wirklich erstaunlich wie
viele dinge man bekommen kann für nur 7
euro pro woche wenn man sich genau
überlegt welche lebensmittel man kauft
und wie man diese kombiniert das wohl
langweiligste gericht was ich mit diesen
zutaten kochen kann ist wohl blank der
als mit salz und genau damit fange ich
heute auch an lange reise ist für
jemanden
ähnlich so gerne kocht zugegebenermaßen
eigentlich gar nicht mal so verkehrt ich
mich hier einfach 500 gramm reis ab und
kippte in einen messbecher das kommt
dann alles in den topf dann messe ich
die doppelte menge an wasser ab und
schütter ist dazu in den topf zum reist
dann noch eine kleine prise salz bund
ein bisschen umrühren und nach ungefähr
zwölf minuten haben wir unseren so meine
lang speise lankreis ich bin mal
gespannt ob ich gut gewürzt haben ja ich
weiß nicht was ich erwarte dass mac
danach reist er ist okay wenn man es
also sag mal lustig klein hat nachschlag
zwar noch nicht ganz am anfang war es
auch echt okay aber je mehr ich davon
ist dass du ich hab zwar hunger aber
irgendwie auch wenn sie mich fühlt es
ist hätte ich nicht so also ich glaube
mein körper weiß nicht was ich damit
anfangen soll
obwohl die ersten zwei teller reis noch
einigermaßen machbar waren war meine
portion zum abendessen nicht ganz so
angenehm und auf die portion am morgen
des nächsten tages hatte ich so wenig
appetit dass ich so gut wie gar nichts
gegessen hat das ist jetzt das gericht
auf das ich mich am allermeisten frei
wir haben einmal die spaghetti mit
tomatensoße und grotte und man macht das
stehe nichts geht ok
[Musik]
also ich sag mal so für ein euro am tag
muss das alles verwertet werden als 100
kommen sich leisten
kann man so machen ich glaube ehrlich
gesagt dass das beste was ich in dieser
woche jemals essen werde so ich glaube
es war eine ziemlich dumme idee dazu ein
weißes hemd anzuziehen aber ich freue
mich jetzt richtig auf die verkostung
es ist eine richtig krasse erlösung
nachdem ich jetzt einfach fünf schüssel
reis gegessen hat die letzten zwei tage
ein bisschen spaghetti mit tomatensoße
es ist erstmal ich habe mega ich hab ja
nur die reste der schweiz werte gegessen
die von gestern und über geblieben sind
ja überlegt ich mache jetzt milchreis
und habt ein tolles rezept dafür
brauchen wir 500 gramm milchreis dann
haben wir vier esslöffel zucker gut wir
haben oder zucker immerhin eine prise
salz sie haben auf jeden fall und zwei
liter milch und die zwei liter milch die
haben wir nicht aber deswegen habe ich
absichtlich mit 3,5 prozentige milch
gekauft weil ich dann einfach ein
bisschen mit wasser verdünnen und das
kommt dann schon hin also es sind harte
zeiten das wird schon das muss reichen
und zimt haben natürlich auch nicht
dafür dass dann auch nicht gereicht
[Applaus]
okay wir essen zum ersten mal in diesen
drei tagen jetzt eine süßspeise
abgesehen von der lukas prehm von der
schon ein bisschen genau starb war ja
ich glaub ich hab ein bisschen angst
dass ich immer noch zu traumatisiert von
diesen reis bin aber der milchreis mit
ordentlich zucker da geht richtig ja das
ist richtig gut es ist viel besser als
mit seidentuch für die beste halbkreis
mit ok den ich erst einmal gegessen
wir machen jetzt was geiles für morgen
und zwar was richtig großes und zwar
brot ja man kann brot einfach selber
machen es funktioniert nicht sagt mir
aus
wirklich ja und da ich so was nicht
hinkriegen wie heute meine freundin
dabei und diese freude wenn man einmal
dabei helfen dieses brot zu backen so
viel macht sich ja übrigens ihr eigenes
brot natürlich von ihrem eigenen geld
weil weil ich jedes einzelne jeden
einzelnen grübel dieses brotes draußen
verlegt und jetzt mit der hand von
manchen der tat noch richtig krass ist
richtig anstrengend vor allem mit dass
das möglich ist das ganze zeug noch in
den tag
deswegen ja stimmt ich dachte das wäre
quatsch zeit hier der wird langsam
härter
die sophie hat übrigen sie einen eigenen
youtube kanal auf dem sie auch gerade
ein video hochgeladen hat indem wir bei
der selbst gemachten nudeln machen also
guck mal eine video beschreibung und
schaute vorbei
neid wieder mal was richtiges essen habe
das wirklich krank als ob ein großer
aussehen kann wenn man selber mal wenn
ich selber noch hält sich das team
brotreste leute ich hab mich so gefreut
endlich mal was richtig geiles los und
dann kommt philosophie und macht so was
kann ich niemals ein butterbrot
wertschätzung
den rest von milchreis und auch vom brot
backe ich einen damit für die nächsten
paar tage noch haltbar ist
es ist gerade der vierte tag und wir
haben auch schon fast halb fünf deswegen
ist daraus auch schon der dunkel und ich
habe mal ein richtig guten tipp für alle
die auch so ein experiment machen wollen
wenn er einfach den ganzen tag lang gar
nix es dann spart ihr euch auch eine
menge geld gesundheitlich wahrscheinlich
nicht so zu empfehlen auf jeden fall
freue ich mich jetzt auf meine erste
mahlzeit und freue mich auch so ein
bisschen tatsächlich dass ich noch so
viel essen überhaupt ganz einfach weil
ich jetzt heute aber nichts gegessen hat
es tut so gut hätte des bundes auch
wegen regens gut geworden
wenn ich als wundermittel habe ich den
ganzen tag nichts essen nicht daran dass
ich heute ein bisschen viel stress hat
ja und ich hatte keine zeit das mal die
kamera aufzustellen um zu essen und ich
wollte natürlich auch nicht ohne euch
erstmal natürlich richtig unhöflichkeit
am rande zu essen es entwickelt sich
langsam immer mehr in richtung endeavour
am ende januar noch und raffiniert essen
überhaupt weil ich einfach so wenig es
was natürlich einerseits wirklich nicht
so toll ist weil ich wirklich oft hunger
hat aber andererseits habe ich jetzt
auch gar keine essens problem ich ja
noch so viel zu essen ich habe noch im
halben kilo reis ich habe auch noch die
halbe packung studenten und die halbe
packung tomatensoße zusätzlich habe ich
nach dem brot hier noch immer einen
ganzen leib und deswegen kann es sogar
sein dass ich diesen halben kilogramm
reis gar nicht mehr in dieser woche ist
muss und so ergibt es sich letztendlich
auch ich mache am abend von tag 5
nochmal erneut spaghetti diese spaghetti
reichen wir bis zum mittag von tage sex
abends esse ich dann noch mal ein halbes
chor mit margarine und am siebten und
letzten tag mache ich den milchreis
sowie das brot leer was heißt dass noch
ein halbes kilo reis über geblieben ist
okay das experiment ist jetzt vorbei und
ich hatte mir ein richtig fetten bürger
bestellt sogar mit doppel
freiheitsrechte dekadent ich glaube man
dass das geil ist als pure reiße ich
weiß natürlich nicht
es ist aufregend bis hin zu fett aber
oh mein gott oh mein gott du bist die
schönste tag meines lebens
gewöhnt aber krass oh mein gott
also ich finde es gegen diese woche okay
abgesehen vom landkreis wer wirklich
horror aber ich glaube ich wäre es nicht
nochmal machen
schlechtes essen schmeckt madrid
deutlich besonders wenn ihr interesse
daran haben schneiden zu lernen dann
kann ich euch die anderen meinen
schnittkurs empfehlen da lernt man ganz
einfach wann und wo man will alles was
man für youtube videos musik videos oder
urlaubsvideos braut den link zum kurs
findet ihr in der video beschreibung
nächste woche am samstag kommt ein video
in dem ich eine ganze woche lang auf
mein handy verzichtet
also wenn ihr das nicht verpassen möchte
dann abonniert diesen kanal und dann
sehen wir zunächst mal wieder alles gut
[Musik]